[Musique]
bonjour quand j'ai commencé mon métier
d'agriculteur il ya dix ans j'ai fait un
rêve
et ce rêve c'était que les agriculteurs
étaient heureux et épanoui d'exercer
leur métier d agriculteur et lé les
sauveurs de l'humanité
waouh sauveur de l'humanité pourquoi
parce que les aviculteurs était capable
de jouer et de faire revenir la
biodiversité était capable d'amener la
santé dans nos assiettes étaient
capables de dépolluer l'eau est filtrée
l'eau et surtout était capable de
stocker du carbone
waouh stocker du carbone stocké le co2
émis par les énergies fossiles
pourquoi comment mais en fait les
agriculteurs sont les seuls qui savent
jouer avec le génie végétal fait le
génie végétal c'est les plantes et donc
les plantes sont capables de capter le
carbone de l'air de le transformer en
végétal ce végétal quand il va mourir
il va se transformer en humus et le sol
va stocker de l'humus donc les plantes
et le génie végétal sauveur de
l'humanité
il ya une dizaine d'années je t ai fait
un peu plus est encore étudiant un peu
rebelle pas vraiment bon élève pas très
adapté au système ou plutôt le système
bada terme en est
j'ai fait un parcours scientifique et
notamment dans ce parcours scientifique
j'ai appris le cycle de l'eau les cycles
du carbone les cycles de la zot tout ça
et travers de ce parcours là j'ai aussi
fait une première année de médecine et
dans cette première année de médecine
j apprenais que les huit maladies
chroniques les plus importantes cancer
alzheimer parkinson diabète et compagnie
le nombre de cas était multiplié par 20
ces 30 dernières années et leur âge
moyen de déclenchement est avancé de 20
ans ont déclenché ces maladies 20 ans
plus tôt mais j'y apprenais aussi que la
de l'alimentation on faisait notre
première médecine
donc il ya des choses qui coulait pas là
et je me disais comment en tant
qu'agriculteur je vais être capable de
produire des aliments sains produire en
respectant la nature et produire un prix
abordable pour le consommateur comment
je pouvais mettre ce rêve en pratique
donc je pensais que les choses seraient
simples que je ferai ça simplement que
ça allait le faire en fait c'est quelque
chose de super génial avec la nature
c'est que systématiquement elle nous
ramène notre enthousiasme à de
l'humilité et elle nous apprend
l'humilité
donc là à cette époque les choses
n'étaient pas simple donc revenons à nos
moutons plutôt un ouvrage ce que je suis
aussi éleveur et quand j'ai repris cette
ferme j'ai fait pas mal d'emprunt pour
racheter le troupeau parce que je ne
suis pas fils d'agriculteur et donc pour
acheter le troupeau racheter le cheptel
c'était un peu compliqué et après
mais là il fallait renouveler le
matériel il fallait payer les fermes
j'avais la banque a remboursé vraiment
les choses étaient très compliqué là
j'ai passé une période assez difficile
et après là il a fallu s'occuper des
vaches et les vaches en fait étaient
souvent malades y allait souvent pas mal
de soucis et là je me suis demandé
qu'est ce que c'est les soucis qu'elles
ont mes vaches et qu'est ce qu'elle
mange mes vaches question qu'est ce que
ça marche des herbivores de l'herbe
voilà mais mes vaches c'est de manger
des graines elles mangeaient de
l'ensilage c'est des céréales fermentées
elle mangeait un peu d'herbe aussi mais
il y avait pas mal de soucis tiens on va
faire une discussion mais qu'est ce que
les taux d'oméga 3 de notre cerveau ont
baissé de moitié en 50 ans pourquoi
est-ce qu'il ya 50 ans les gens
mangeaient plus de poissons gras plus de
sushis c'était ça sûrement en fait il ya
50 ans les vaches les herbivores manger
plus d'herbe donc les herbivores manger
de l'herbe c'est à dire que les viandes
que l'on mangé étaient des viandes qui
avait où les vaches avaient mangé de
l'herbe et le lait et les fromages tous
les produits laitiers comme angers
c'était du lait de vache qui mangeait
plus ce dernier est donc là la question
se pose c'est comment on fait pour être
aussi productifs avec de l'herbe parce
que c'est bien beau tout ça mais la
santé on ne produit pas donc en fait en
1957 il ya un gars qui a écrit un livre
au moment où l'anglais coûtait pas cher
et au moment où c'était début de la
révolution industrielle
ce gars il a fait un recueil de tout ce
qui s'est passé avant dans les dents
toutes les études des abbayes et
campagne et est donc là dedans il a cru
qu il a mélangé tout ça et il a établi
des principes du quelque chose qui
s'appelle le pâturage tournant dynamique
et ses principes de pâturage tournant
dynamique c'est qu'on va prendre des
animaux beaucoup d'animaux sur une toute
petite surface qui vont fonctionner sur
une tendance à lui passé peut être un
axe d'entrée très courts et en restant
très peu de temps sur cette surface
elles vont manger toute l'aide et elles
vont changer de place après et ça va
laisser à l'herbe le temps de repousser
donc à chaque fois que le troupeau va
revenir il va manger de l'herbe au stade
optimal
petite anecdote ce gala il est c'est un
héros internationales dans tous les pays
de pâturage que ce soit l'uruguay soit
la nouvelle zélande que ce soit
l'australie voilà mais en france
personne ne connaît pas ce que on n'y
est pas encore et donc ça reproduit le
comportement des troupeaux dans la
savane
donc en fait on peut voir les vaches qui
se promène tout le temps la tête en bas
elles mangeaient le manque je le mange
et donc ça c'est là où ça commence à
être intéressant c'est que sont tout le
temps en train de manger elle piétine
plus elles sont en train de se promener
pour chercher de la nourriture et donc
elles font plus de dégâts
qu'est-ce que ça comme conséquences sur
la productivité sur la production ce
système
donc on a parlé de la santé des animaux
et la santé des hommes ce système
s'avère que la plante végétal laird pour
arriver à pousser d'une certaine
quantité à une identité plus grande
comment on va la laisser repousser plus
elle va faire plus de racines en faisant
plus de racines va permettre à l'eau de
s'infiltrer plus dans le sol et autre
chose c'est que les animaux en déféquant
de manière assez aléatoire sur la
parcelle vont permettre aussi aux vers
de terre de nourrir un peu plus le
système est donc en nourrissant un peu
plus ce système on se rend compte que
les taux du must du sol taux de matière
organique du sol de ces systèmes la
augmente
en fait avec ces systèmes là on est
capable de capter du carbone voilà c'est
nouveau on a des systèmes d'élevage qui
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
donc ça ça commence à être intéressant
mais c'est ceci ce système d'élevage
c'est à dire qu'il faut le maîtriser
bien est en fait la productivité des
prairies aux mains de chaque année bon
maintenant les cultures quand j'ai
repris la ferme
ça ressemblait un peu à ça c'est à dire
que travailler le sol et quand on
travaille et le sol en petite anecdote
par rapport au travail de sol est ce que
vous pensez
comment comment est le berceau des
premières civilisations
le croissant fertile commencé après 8000
ans d'agriculture c'est fertile est ce
que vous pensez qu'ils ont construit les
pyramides dans le désert ben non en fait
c'était hyper verdoyant autrefois et en
travaillant le sol on va casser le les
systèmes biologiques qui permettent de
retenir la terre est systématiquement
quand il ya un orage
quand vous voyez une rivière marron
quand vous passez à côté d'une rivière
marron c'est de la terre des champs
agricoles qui cirait qui est partie et
se terrent descharles agricole c'est
toujours la meilleure terre c'est la
partie la plus fertile et en fait on a
plus 300 affaires les andouilles avec ce
système là c'est à dire que notre
système agricole ce qu'ils ont réussi à
faire en huit mille ans non on va
réussir à faire la même chose en 300 ans
donc si on veut pas qu'ils aient du
désert ça s'est terminé
donc il ya des choses qui étaient assez
difficiles dans ma dans mon parcours et
notamment par rapport aux au labour en
fait donc ce que vous avez vu surtout
diapos c'est le labour est donc le
labour ça
l'acte de retourner le sol pose pas mal
de soucis est en fait un jour en 2000
ans toujours c'est mon oncle qui
labourait et un jour en 2011
donc la bourre et c'est l'acte de votre
nez vrai en 2011 il ya une parcelle
entente assez loin de la ferme à
travailler et je lui dis me demande s'il
peut y aller comme d'habitude et tout et
puis pas du tout envie d aller donc il
me dit tu te débrouilles était paysan ou
tuent les parents j'avais jamais conduit
la charrue fait avec le traité avec la
charrue et à la charge en fait à chaque
bout de ligne il faut la tourner pour
reprendre la ligne dans l'autre sens et
là c'était des pentes assez importante
et plusieurs fois j'ai failli chavirer
j'ai failli me retourner et je me suis
dit je vais pas me tuer à ça plus jamais
quand qu'est ce que c'est le métier de
paysan est ce que c'est ça avoir labouré
ou est-ce que c'est connaître les sols
connaître la biologie connaître l
agronomie et là je me suis dit je vais
passer du travail de sol simplifiée donc
j'ai diminué la profondeur de sol
travaillé et en diminuant la profondeur
de sol travaillé là je me suis dit que
j'allais réduire le travail de sol
réduire les phyto réduire les pesticides
etc ça allait bien se passer
bon là ça c'est pas super bien passé
mais dont classe de la chance que j'ai
eue c'est que parallèlement à ça on a
commencé à mettre en place avec au pays
basque la chance d'être dans un
territoire militants une bande de
collègues agriculteurs et une structure
d'accompagnement locale qui s'appelle
rachel j
on a commencé à mettre en place des
filières courtes de valorisation donc on
a fait du père local on a fait de l'orge
locales pour faire de la bière locale a
pas mal bataille est donc ça ça
permettait d'avoir des prix un peu plus
important pour la valorisation des
produits puis ça ça va aussi obligé h en
sortir de la monoculture donc à faire
une diversité de cultures et donc après
le fait que les choses se soient pas
aussi bien passée quand je faisais mon
travail de sol réduit en réduisant les
phyto réduisant les anglais et compagnie
mais je me suis j'ai compris qu'il
manquait une clé du manque une
gigantesque clé
la clé c'était l'agronomie il ya quelque
chose qu'il faut retenir et c'est pas
valable que pour la
et culture c'est que nous ne devons pas
construire la nature comme fonctionnent
nos pensées mais nous devons construire
nos pensées comme fonctionne la nature
donc après je suis passé au semis direct
le semis direct qu'est ce que c'est sans
transition
c'est qu'on va faire tousser des plantes
qui vont venir nourrir le sol nourrir la
biologie du sol qui va travailler à
notre place mais moi je roule le ce
qu'on appelle le couvert végétal parce
que je suis en bio maintenant donc j'ai
voulu droit à la chimie ensuite on va
utiliser un semoir qui va positionner la
graine à l'intérieur de ce paillage le
paillage va mourir va se décomposer
progressivement va nourrir le système et
la culture pouce au travers et protéger
le sol est protégé et donc ça c'est une
culture de soja avec un très haut
rendement et surtout l'avantagé de ce
système là c'est que ça coûte très peu
cher à mettre en place
il n'y a pas de désherbage mécanique qui
a pas de ça on est sûr à peu près 10
litres 13 litres de gasoil ha roulage
compris comparé à certains systèmes bio
qui sont à 120 litres
donc on dépense énormément moins
d'énergies fossiles pour produire ces
choses là
maintenant vous êtes un petit ver de
terre qu'est ce que vous préférez vous
préférez quand vous retournez votre
maison chaque année 1 vous préférez donc
il faut la reconstruire et se replace
pas simple vous préférez que quand vous
enlève juste le toit mais pour
reconstruire le toit ou vous préférez
quand vous la laisse pour se protéger
contre les agressions du soleil de la
pluie des diverses et aux traditions
qu'est ce qui est bien mais là le ver de
terre se dit c'est cool mais il est
gentil avec moi
voilà mais c'est pas suffisant donc
c'est pas suffisant
c'est qu'en fait la biologie et cette
biodiversité pour qu'elles bossent pour
moi parce que c'est pas que je travaille
plus le sol c'est que c'est la biologie
qui va travailler à ma place ça commence
à être un peu plus intéressant mais pour
que ça marche il faut la nourrir
et donc on va nourrir les sols pour
nourrir les plantes pour nourrir les
hommes
et ça avec une nourriture diversifié
vous mangerez vous 365 jours par an un
matin midi et soir des frites au bout
d'un moment ça va être difficile à
digérer le sol c'est paris si on veut
qu'il fonctionne correctement il faut le
nourrir avec nourriture diversifiée donc
il faut des plans de cas tirées
pollinisateurs des plantes qui vont
aller avec des racines très profondes
dans le fond du profil il faut des
plantes qui capte ce qui est gratuit
dans l'air on a vu que ça capte et du
co2 mais ça peut aussi capter de la zot
l'air et composés d'azoté et donc il ya
certaines familles de plantes qui capte
l azote donc ça évite d'utiliser d azote
de synthèse sera en tout cas une dans
les systèmes bio c'est obligatoire au
sommet voilà donc il faut une diversité
de familles de plantes et donc à partir
non une diversité de familles de plantes
on retrouve de la biodiversité
auxiliaires qui va nous rendre des
services écosystémiques
ça veut dire tout ce qui est vivant dans
le sol va accompagner le système de
production vers quelque chose de
vertueux et donc on va voir des
champignons en cas ici on est une photo
de filaments de champignons qui
multiplie par cinq mille la capacité
d'absorption des racines on a des
carabins qui vont aller détruire les
limaces on a qui vont manger des stocks
de graines c'est les petites bestioles
en haut à droite il ya tout plein de
diversité qui apparaît et qui nous
rendent des services donc la suite de
tout ça c'est
que sur la santé en mettant en place ces
systèmes sommes dans des tentes qui sont
plus riches en antioxydants est plus
riche en oligo éléments parce que son
mieux nourrie par le système sol et
quand le haut est lessivé dans un champ
travail et ils partent pas que l'azoté
le phosphore et le pote et la potasse il
partout les oligo-éléments aussi est
donc là on il faut éviter les fuites
dans les systèmes ensuite on a un impact
colossal sur lot lot va s'infiltrer à
s'infiltrer profondément dans le profil
des racines vont permettre aux plantes
les restaurants permettre à l'eau de
descendre très profondément est en fait
en descendant très profondément le sol
va être capable de stocker plus d'eau
donc moins besoin d'irrigation plus de
résilience et d'adaptabilité par rapport
aux événements extrêmes et a changé la
couverture végétale aussi protège la
surface par rapport à des élévations de
température aussi biologie du sol est
capable de dépolluer l'eau mais en fait
ce qui nous intéresse c'est que de notre
côté on a utilisé moins d'énergies
fossiles mais là aujourd'hui en un
système agricole traditionnelle qui est
responsable entre 30 et 40% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre donc
on est en guerre on met en garde contre
le réchauffement climatique
si on ne change pas à commencer par le
modèle agricole
on est tous faire on a perdu la guerre
mais on peut la gagner et on peut la
gagner cette guerre pourquoi parce que
ce système sol quand on va lui laisser
de l'humus à la surface et qu'on va -
décapitaliser la matière organique dans
le sol en arrêtant le travail de sol et
en utilisant des techniques de semis
direct sous couvert en faisant ces
systèmes là on est capable de stocker du
carbone stocké du carbone
c'est ce qui s'appelle le plan 4 pour
mille vous pouvez trouver ça sur le le
site des nations unies c'est qu'un taux
de croissance annuel du stock de carbone
dans les sols de 0 4% soit 4 pour 1000
par an permet de stopper l'augmentation
de la concentration du co2 dans
l'atmosphère liée aux activités humaines
ce plan là s'appelle les soldes pour la
sécurité alimentaire et le climat les
gars qui font ça depuis 20 ans ils sont
pas 4 pour mille ils sont à 25 pour
mille on peut le faire on sait le faire
maintenant il faut basculer et donc ce
système là tout ça c'est l'agroécologie
pour la première fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité on sait produire de la
nourriture en grosse quantité en ayant
un impact positif sur notre
environnement et l'agro écologie c'est
vraiment le seul espoir de survie de la
vie est le seul espoir de survie de
notre espèce
[Applaudissements]